– Hola, Nico!
– Pepe!
– Wie geht’s?
– Okay …
Du hast gesagt, …
– Ich habe einen Job für dich, richtig.
Aber du hast einfach aufgelegt.
– Tut mir leid. Die Situation, in der du
angerufen hast, die war’n bisschen ... blöd.
– Okay.
– Gibt’s den Job noch?
– Ja.
– Und …
was ist das für eine Arbeit?
– Es ist ein Praktikum am Filmset.
– Beim Film?
– Ja. Ein Team dreht hier bald eine
aktuelle Serie fürs Fernsehen,
bei der du mitarbeiten kannst.
– Wirklich?
– Ja, wirklich.
Die Serie ist ziemlich lustig.
– Und ... was soll ich da machen?
– Na ja, du hilfst, wo du kannst.
Du bringst dem Team Kaffee. Du passt auf,
dass kein Fußgänger in die Szene läuft.
Solche Sachen.
– Klasse!
Ich liebe Serien!
– Na ja.
Ich schau am liebsten Dokumentationen.
– Könntest du …?
– Ich muss den Leuten, mit denen ich
gesprochen habe,
noch heute eine Zusage geben.
Sonst ist das Angebot weg.
Also?
– Okay!
Danke!
– Gerne.